-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from his work
on HBO's "Silicon Valley."
He stars in the CBS sitcom
"B Positive."
The season-two finale
airs March 10th.
Let's take a look.
-Knock knock.
-Don't answer.
-Who's there?
-Nobody home.
-Juneau.
-I'm great at these.
Juneau who?
-Did you know [Juneau]
I'm headed to Alaska?
-Oh!
-"Did you know
I'm headed to Alaska" who?
-Uh, no, no, no.
I'm going to Alaska.
I finally decided
on my next adventure.
-Why is that funny?
-I might try to work
on a fishing boat
after, you know, I spend a few
weeks exploring the wilderness,
just me and nature
in an epic battle for survival.
-My money's on nature.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Thomas Middleditch,
everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, it is just
so nice to have you here,
and I feel as though
this might be
a television debut
of a new hairstyle.
-Well, you know...
[ Laughter ]
...it's the cut
that everybody's talking about.
-Yeah.
I heard you had a new one,
and I will admit,
when you first walked out,
I didn't really see it.
It wasn't until I got you
on this angle, as you went...
-Yeah, that looks like
a pretty normal haircut.
"Oh, what's that?" you say?
"It's a braided rat tail
at the back?"
[ Laughter ]
-I mean --
-And I want to say,
this is real.
[ Laughter ]
This isn't some ha-ha funny
for-jokes extension.
This is my life now.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This isn't one of those
phony Hollywood rat tails
you get on Sunset Boulevard.
-Those are a dime a dozen,
my friend.
-I mean, that must have taken,
what, a half a week to grow?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
It's a little short now...
...but this baby's gonna
get down to my butt, hopefully.
-Wow!
-I can whip it around, like...
-This is such a big life change.
-Yeah!
-What makes you take the leap
to rat tail?
-You know, you just --
you get some free time,
and, uh, things change.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of introspection,
and I come out --
I emerge from my cocoon
a tailed man.
[ Laughter ]
-We've talked about this before,
and I feel a little --
Like, I have to admit to you,
I don't really believe it
when we talk about the fact
that you have a pilot's license.
-What about me makes you not
take me seriously, Seth?
[ Laughter ]
-When you go to your barber,
you're like, "Just remember,
you need to see it
under, like, a helmet.
The rat tail's gotta
be long enough."
-It's got to poke out.
Any headwear, ya gotta see it.
[ Laughter ]
-But this is your --
So, again, you are using
your piloting for good.
I think sometimes people
might think,
"Oh, he got his pilot license,
he's out there, you know,
going to probably
the Fyre Festival
or something like that."
[ Laughter ]
You -- This is a true thing.
You have been going,
and you've been ferrying dogs
from one, like,
rescue to another.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
They're like,
"Aww, that's not what I thought
from the rat-tail guy."
-"I thought he was gonna
take drugs up from Mexico.
What the hell?"
[ Laughter ]
No, but there are
drugs in the dogs.
Don't worry about it.
[ Laughter ]
No. No, there's an organization,
Pilots N Paws, where basically
they act as, like, a middleman.
So, you know,
shelters will be full
in Southern California,
and they need to get flown up
to places with more room
or occasionally
their new forever home.
And it's kind of a way to be,
like, do something nice,
get an excuse to fly around,
and then you'll end up in, like,
some random spot.
Like, I find myself in places
like Placerville
or Grass Valley,
up in Northern California,
which are, like...I guess,
towns that were founded on,
like, the California gold rush.
-Oh!
-And they remind you of it.
Every bar is like,
The Old Klondike Saloon!
[ Laughter ]
"Have a sarsaparilla
at the Pioneers Tavern!"
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, got it.
Copy that.
You like your gold."
-I like that I was like,
"How do you even get
a rescue dog in a plane?
What do they --
How do they travel?"
-They curl up, man.
-Look at that.
Oh. Those two --
Those two were great.
They were two Brittany spaniels
who had, like,
this neurological condition.
So when I picked them up,
they were like --
I forget their names.
Like, "Mitzi and Barbara,
and here they are,"
and they're like,
"Guh-guh-guh guh-guh!"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Oh, boy!
Are they gonna settle down
when we fly?"
'Cause they're sitting in
the back like, "Guh-guh-guh."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, yeah, I am laughing
at them, but it was --
[ Laughter ]
It's sweet.
Sometimes those brain conditions
are hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
-You travel with your dog,
so your dog comes, too.
-I do, yes.
Well, yeah, I travel
with one of them, Potter,
and I go up high.
-Uh-huh.
-And when you're up high,
and my plane is not pressurized,
you need oxygen.
-So even a dog needs oxygen?
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So is this something
you can buy,
or did you rig this yourself?
-[ Laughs ]
It would be cool if I rigged it.
I'm like,
"He's got to get air somehow!"
No, you buy this.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And so...this is in
his little sweater,
and he's got earmuffs
and his little Bane mask.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
I really like that one.
-Yeah.
-He gets really --
And what's weird is, like,
when he's -- when he's
oxygen-deprived
or just getting enough,
he gets real cuddly.
So, that's, like, him, like,
crawling on me and being like,
"Sleep now, master?"
"Yes."
[ Laughter ]
"Go to bed now, child."
-"Yes, in the morning,
you'll get more air."
-"Only when I
deem it necessary."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitating air hissing ]
-Yeah.
I am, I am, uh...
I'm is it Michael Ironside
in "Total Recall"?
I'm the bad guy
in "Total Recall."
-Yeah, Michael Ironside.
Nice pull.
-Yeah.
-And they were impressed.
-Yeah, you guys --
[ Laughter ]
Why aren't you up to date
on Arnold Schwarzenegger,
Sharon Stone,
and Michael Ironside's
"Total Recall"?
[ Laughter ]
"Screw you, Benny!"
[ Grunts ]
-Oh, there, see?
Now they're just coming --
Now they're slowly remembering,
yeah.
-"I wish I had three hands."
"You're just doing fine
with two."
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a spicy scene.
Now, that's a spicy scene.
[ Laughter ]
-Just doubling down,
doubling down, doubling down.
-It's one of the best!
[ Light laughter ]
Sorry for getting too animated
over "Total Recall."
I feel like everyone's like,
"Settle Down."
-You flew with one of your dogs.
That means you have another.
That doesn't go up with you?
-No, I realize that her time
of traveling is done.
-An older dog.
-She's an elder.
She's about 15.
The fun part about her,
and what has been a great gift,
on top of just years
of great news, globally,
is that she has lost
the full-functioning use
of her hind legs
and just rear half.
-Okay.
-So she has a little wheelchair
that I put her in.
She, like, rolls around.
-All right.
-And the real cherry
on the cake...
[ Laughter ]
...is that, before bed --
and I am aware that
I'm talking about this
on television...
-Okay, good.
-...in order to, like,
lessen the chances of me
waking up the next morning
with a stinky treat,
I have to --
as instructed by my vet --
I have to encourage a movement,
uh, manually.
-Okay.
-So I take a little bag and I,
like, carry her to a spot,
I hold her up, and I, uh,
you know, um...
play with my dog's butthole.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And --
And I don't love it.
I hate it.
But I do it every night.
And I'm happy.
The reward for it
is dump in my hand.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm in my neighborhood,
like, in the dark, doing this.
Like, other people walking by
are, like,
walking by me like, "Jesus."
I'm like,
"Uh, the vet told me to!"
[ Laughter ]
It is -- It is really --
It's a real morale booster.
[ Laughter ]
-Just 'cause, your whole day,
you know you've got that
waiting at the end.
-I know, I got to milk
my dog later on.
[ Laughter ]
And it's not like the normal --
the other, Potter, it's not like
he's any better,
'cause, like, it's late.
You know,
you just want to go to bed,
and dogs are such
jerks about it.
They're, like,
you can tell they need to poo,
but they're like, "Here? No."
[ Laughter ]
"Here? Nunh-unh."
And you're like, "I can see
your body ready to go, and
you're still denying me this."
And then, when they do it,
you're like, "Yes!"
And then you're, like,
this sad man, happy for poo.
[ Laughter ]
What is your life right now?
And I'm so acquainted
with how poo feels now.
I'm like -- I always say,
if it's dry, you're like,
"There's more in there,"
and now I'm sitting there
trying to get more out of her.
It's so --
It's so sad.
[ Laughter ]
We got enough to deal with.
-Yeah!
-Anyway, I'm crushing it, man.
[ Laughter ]
-You got the rat tail.
-I got a rat tail...
[ Both laugh ]
...doing poo stuff...
-You're a great dog owner.
Let's not --
"B Positive" is a wonderful show
with a wonderful cast.
You mentioned in that clip,
your character was gonna go
to Juneau, Alaska,
work on a fishing boat.
Now that you're a man
of the air, have you ever
thought about life on the sea,
maybe getting a fishing license
or something?
-Oh, no, that's, uh,
far too, uh, um, bloody for me.
No, I, uh --
I have actually,
only recently --
When the pandemic started,
I had, um...
I think I was googling --
or, YouTube'ing "squalls,"
"white squalls," because there's
this Canadian folk singer
called Stan Rogers,
who sings, like, sea shanties.
And I was like, "Mm. I wonder
what a white squall is."
And like, "Oh, wow.
That's pretty stormy."
And then, YouTube,
later on, was like,
"I hear you're into sailing."
And I'm like,
"Not really,
but what do you got, YouTube?"
And YouTube is like,
"Well, there's this --
there's this channel,
these, like --
They're both so pretty.
There's this, like,
pretty Australian couple,
the man and a woman, who have
detached themselves from life.
They sail around the world,
sailing the Vagabond.
I'll give you a shout-out!
Why not?
I bought their merch.
I'm weirdly obsessed
with sailing now.
And, uh, yeah, they live at sea,
and I have thought about
just like, "You know what?
That's it for me, boys."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "I'll take to the seas
from now on."
But I have a feeling, like,
I don't know, a week in,
I would just be like,
"I want my Xbox.
What am I doing?"
-Yeah.
-"What am I doing?"
-"I can't believe I'm on a boat
with a dog that can't [bleep]
on his own."
[ Laughter ]
-In a white squall.
"Come on, Meatloaf!"
[ Laughter ]
"Give me the goods, baby,
give me that brown gold!"
-Is his name Meatloaf?
-Her name is Meatloaf!
Don't mis-gender my dog!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, God.
-It's 2022.
Please don't mis-gender
my dog, Seth!
[ Laughter ]
I'm begging you.
-All right, I hear you!
Apologies to Meatloaf.
She sounds wonderful.
-Yes.
-This is Thomas Middleditch,
everybody.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The season-two finale
of "B Positive"
airs March 10th on CBS.